[Music]
this pretzel shaped collection of
galaxies is our universe and it's about
to collide with another universe it
might be fascinating to watch but we
should probably be worried about what's
going to happen when they crash how
would it change the physics of our
universe is there any chance that we
would survive
what would the collision look like from
Earth and has it ever happened before
this is what if and here's what would
happen if our universe collided with
another one the only potential evidence
of a universal collision that we've ever
discovered is in the form of a cold spot
in our universe in 2013 the European
Space Agency's Planck satellite
confirmed that this area is 1.8 billion
light years across it's much colder than
the rest of space and it seems to be
missing
10,000 galaxies at first scientists were
baffled by its existence but now some
have theorized that this spot might be a
kind of scar or bruise left from
colliding with another universe but how
can we know for sure and if this is the
case how long before it happens again
[Music]
before we go any further let me take a
second to address something that might
have some of you scratching your heads
usually when we refer to the universe
we're talking about all space and time
including planets stars galaxies and all
other forms of matter and energy so if
the universe basically means everything
in existence then logically there can
only be one of them right
not necessarily some scientists believe
in the concept of the multiverse this
theory states that our universe wasn't
the only one that popped into existence
during the Big Bang that there's an
infinite number of other universes out
there too and we just haven't found a
way to see or measure them yet if this
theory is right then it's possible that
all these other universes could have
grown at the same rate at the same time
after the Big Bang if that's the case
then they might have banged into each
other as they expanded and that brings
us back to the cold spot the cold spot
is a region of our universe that's
0.0001 5 degrees colder than everywhere
else that might not seem like a big deal
but when the rest of the universe's
temperature is so consistent scientists
have started to think it's something
more than an anomaly they think that the
cold spot might be a scar leftover from
a collision between universes and the
crash might have moved a bit of energy
out of that spot in our universe causing
the colder temperature but what what a
collision of that magnitude look like
we can't say for sure but there are some
pretty cool ideas out there according to
one physicist at the University of
California if another universe came
crashing into ours it would look like a
giant mirror in the sky rushing towards
us because its wall would reflect light
if this other universe collided with our
own we could inherit a whole new set of
governing laws of physics gravity could
weaken or disappear resulting in a slew
of planets escaping the gravity of their
stars sending them flying off into space
at ridiculous speeds without gravity
stars would cease to exist and we'd be
left in perpetual darkness this would
make life on Earth and throughout most
of the universe nearly impossible with
no shining stars we'd lose any means of
nourishment or breathable air as plants
would no longer be capable of
transforming starlight into energy
through photosynthesis but as bad as
that all sounds it's not something we've
really have to worry about since the
chances of our universe colliding with
another one are slim to none for one
thing we're not even sure that there are
other universes out there to collide
with and even if there are any
collisions would have happened at that
point when they were expanding 380,000
years after the Big Bang which would
mean there's little to no chance of it
happening again if you're going to worry
about colliding with anything maybe you
should pick something a little more
realistic like an asteroid
ah but that's a story for another what
if
[Music]